die scheidung ist besiegelt mit 358 234
stimmen verabschiedete das britische
unterhaus das eben austritts gesetz doch
nach der trennung ist vor einem
handelsabkommen mit der eu
und das kann schwierig werden als boris
johnson in der vergangenen woche eine
absolute parlamentsmehrheit gewann
hofften viele er werde nun einen
versöhnlicheren kurs einschlagen einen
weicheren dragset anstreben sowie die
mehrheit der briten in immer noch
wünscht stattdessen hat johnson
zugeständnisse die die opposition in den
vergangenen monaten mühsam erkämpft
hatte aus dem abkommen gestrichen
das wichtigste das parlament hat bei den
künftigen verhandlungen mit der eu
keinerlei mitspracherecht mehr
und das ist der zeitplan für die
verhandlungen am ersten februar beginnt
die übergangsperiode großbritannien
bleibt im binnenmarkt unter zollunion
unter zeit mit der eu ein freihandels
und partnerschafts abkommen
abzuschließen
spätestens im oktober sollte dann ein
vertrag vorliegen damit er rechtzeitig
ratifiziert wird und am 31 12 2020 der
praxis komplett vollzogen werden kann
aus eu sicht wäre eine längere
übergangsphase vernünftig die aber
müssten die briten beantragen
tun sie das nicht dann bleiben genau elf
monate für das aushandeln und die
ratifizierung eines freihandels vertrags
das ist nach meinung von experten extrem
knapp kalkuliert zum vergleich bis zum
abschluss des freihandels vertrag
zwischen der eu und kanada vergingen
ganze sieben jahre folter so nennt boris
johnson die immer wieder verschobenen
dragset austritts termine das soll es
mit ihm nicht mehr geben deswegen hat er
ende 2020 als ende der übergangsphase
gesetzlich festgeschrieben vermutlich
gelingt es brüssel und london bis dahin
nur eine art rom vertrag zu erstellen
der dann in den kommenden jahren mit
vielen vielen details gefüllt werden
muss johnstons idee dass bis dahin das
thema aus der öffentlichen debatte
verschwunden ist und niemand mehr das
wort exit in den mund nimmt scheint ein
frommer wunsch
baustellen gibt es viele nicht nur im
handel auch was den finanzsektor
dienstleistungen oder auch die rechte
der eu-bürger in großbritannien und
andersherum betrifft ein
freihandelsabkommen in elf monaten
hinzukriegen kann eigentlich nur
gelingen wenn die briten bereit wären
auch weiterhin eu standards zu
akzeptieren zum beispiel im umwelt-
arbeits- und sozialbereich im moment
aber deutet alles darauf hin dass die
briten genau das nicht wollen und dann
hätten wir im nächsten jahr um diese
zeit eine weitere praxis hängepartie es
muss also schnell gehen sonst droht
sogar der ungeordnete brax it inklusive
grenzkontrollen und zellen